[Music]
the loud house is one of the most
popular Nickelodeon shows around but do
you know everything about this show from
banned episodes and weird rumors to a
controversial creator check out what
you've missed
don't forget to hit that notification
bell to never miss another video and be
sure to check out our community section
for even more fun now let's check out
some dark truths behind the loud house
making history but not everyone is on
board everyone loves the loud house
right well not everyone the truth is
many countries hate it because they feel
like this shows progressive character
development isn't in line with their own
laws of course we're talking about LGBTQ
rights and we all know the loud house
doesn't shy away from it in the loud
house Clyde has two dads which is
something that's never been done before
in the history of Nickelodeon it's
something to be proud of something to
celebrate right a cartoon with LGBTQ
characters is unheard of as it is and
it's one of the reasons why the loud
house is so loved and respected well
there are some countries who just aren't
on board with openly showing a gay
couple so they decided to ban the show
entirely like Africa the show is
completely banned there for this exact
reason but not only because of gay dads
clients dads are also biracial
homosexuality is harshly punished in for
African countries an outlawed in 36
countries out of 54 nickelodeon Africa
confirmed that it will not air the loud
house as it's not in line with the
continents faith in religion so while
the show is in fact making history
Africa just isn't on board ratings
battle it's no secret that the loud
house and SpongeBob SquarePants are in a
ratings battle yep you heard that right
the loud house actually managed to
surpass one of Nickelodeon's most
popular shows ever everyone loves this
feel-good show but the most interesting
part of this tidbit is the fact that
SpongeBob SquarePants creators have
rarely commented on the loud house at
all meanwhile the loud houses frequently
featured cameos of spongebob characters
and Chris Savino the creator of the show
always made sure spongebob is mentioned
and tributed after all in order to
create the greatest nickel owed
show you have to take inspiration from
the actual greatest Nickelodeon show
right
so how come spongebob squarepants hasn't
really return this favor people are
still waiting for that crossover between
SpongeBob SquarePants in the loud house
but considering the one-way tributes it
doesn't seem like that's gonna happen
anytime soon hopefully the people behind
SpongeBob SquarePants won't hold grudges
against the loud house and eventually
give the fans what they want
despite the beating and ratings but the
silence really does make you wonder
doesn't it L is for love B is for band
Alice for love is one of the most
beloved episode of the show we've
already touched on the LGBT factor of
the loud house but Clyde's dads aren't
the only one that are shown as LGBT
characters it's revealed that Luna
actually has a crush on a girl hinting
that she's at least bisexual as it's
been shown she also has a crush on boys
again this is something everyone should
celebrate right well once again some
countries didn't take this revelation
lightly after the episode aired turkey
banned the entire show and it reportedly
took about ten months for it to return
it's also been reported that the episode
was skipped on the Arabian Malaysian
Turkish and Russian dubs as those
countries have strong laws that aren't
exactly friendly to the LGBT community
so while the episode is generally loved
by the public some countries just
couldn't accept the whole L is for love
mantra but despite the negative response
from these countries L is for love is
without a doubt one of the cutest loud
house episodes deaf are absolutely
adorable inappropriate jokes
despite its positive outlook the loud
house has plenty of inappropriate jokes
that might make your parents gasp and
turn off the TV this is pretty typical
for every Nickelodeon TV show so it's no
wonder the loud house couldn't escape
this narrative for example in serial
offender the kids can be seen at the
grocery store and some really
questionable words come out of Lynn's
mouth
market shoppers
we all knew what mother shoppers really
stood for Lynn ties that bind is also an
episode where the entire plot was
actually pretty inappropriate because of
a misunderstanding the kids thought
their parents were only able to keep one
of them and the rest would get kicked
out of the house is that really funny
you can find plenty of more adult jokes
that will probably end up going over a
kid's head but they'll definitely raise
an adult I bro the loud house sure knows
how to keep things controversial after
all it's a show about a lot of siblings
and siblings do sometimes have
inappropriate jokes right moments we
wish we could forget what are perhaps
the most disturbing episodes ever came
from season 2 episode 4 called sweet and
sour we hardly ever see the parents
around the loud house but when they are
we can be sure they're part of a really
interesting plot in this case it's a
plot we really wish we could forget do
you remember this episode it's when the
family goes to a small resort and the
kids go crazy as the parents have some
time to themselves although it wasn't
directly shown the parents actually went
skinny-dipping talk about inappropriate
you can see them shouting Marco Polo but
what's even worse is they get kicked out
of the hotel for it and then promised to
each other they won't tell the kids
about it until they're older of course
when they're back home they race to the
hot tub to enjoy some more alone time
seriously though we kind of wish we'd
never seen this at all considering no
one really wants to watch parents play
their own version of Marco Polo that was
honestly a bit too much which makes it
our dark truth about that specific
episode a spin-off did you hear that the
loud house became so popular it actually
announced a spinoff although the
character in this spin-off wasn't really
that present it seems like they're
trying to do another take on the iconic
Dora the Explorer to bring some
diversity and quite possibly additional
languages into everyday life the
spin-off is called las Casas Grandes and
it focuses on Ronnie Ann and her family
as they move to the city and try to make
it one day
this spinoff was announced in March of
2018 but as of July 2018 there hasn't
been any more news on the show we do
know that season 3 of the loud house
also features a 5 episode feature of
running Ann and her family in the hopes
to promote the new spin-off the question
is was that spin-off created with the
intention to end the popularity of the
loud house and continue with the show
that's much more diverse and
multicultural or will the two shows be
running simultaneously and we get to
enjoy the best of both worlds we'll have
to wait and see for that one but we do
hope that las Casas Grandes is just a
spin-off and nothing more the lost
episode theory if you spend enough time
on the loud house forum you're likely to
stumble upon this extremely dark story
although it's not necessarily the truth
it's a story that sets shivers down our
spines and many suspect it to be 100%
true
while others of course doubt its actual
existence this particular episode gained
popularity from the creepypasta website
where a person stated that they've
discovered a lost episode that left them
completely shocked the episode is called
enough is enough
and it talks about Lincoln basically
having it up to here with his siblings
who are often not very nice to him we
all know Lincoln gives more than he
takes so who knows maybe he actually
snapped in the episode Lincoln does some
really terrible things to his sisters
and while the episode is most likely
made up there are some who do believe
that it could be true the writing in the
descriptions are incredibly convincing
and the story even includes a gory
screenshot of what happens to Laurie
after Lincoln snaps but we're pretty
sure that if this was ever real the loud
house creator would be in a lot more
trouble than he already is watch until
the end to find out what we're talking
about Lincoln's treatment but first
let's talk about something many fans
have started to notice as they watch the
show
Lincoln loud is the typical middle child
we all know that stereotypically middle
children are often ignored but fans have
noticed that all the attention is on
Lincoln well negative attention a
deviant art user pointed out that the
loud house sisters are so
negative toward Lincoln it sometimes
makes it really hard to watch they'll
often throw mean-spirited jokes at him
and do whatever they can to make his
life totally miserable and while it's
true that siblings do that to each other
it seems unfair that most sisters seem
to gang up on Lincoln while all he wants
to do is help them Lincoln seems to be
the family's main protagonist as well as
antagonists at the same time and all of
his personality is usually fueled by his
sisters depending on which sister he
interacts with his treatment has been
noted as completely unfair in many fans
hoped that his character arc will
eventually improve although considering
we're on season three of the loud house
and Lincoln is still constantly picked
on it might be a while until that
happens what's happening to the movie
everyone's talking about the loud house
movie including the fans but the truth
is this movie is nothing but a rumor
with the spin-off Las Casas Grandes not
even available on IMDB yet we have a
feeling the voice actors of the loud
house will be pretty busy for the next
few years
imagine filming a spin-off a movie and a
regular show or around the same time we
wonder how that one would play out since
the loud house frequently uses the same
voice actors for multiple characters
it's going to be a busy few years for
the cast if both the movie and Las Casas
Grandes gets an OK so far not much is
known about a movie other than most of
the loud house cast are rumored to be a
part of it well that does make sense no
one really knows if it's actually
happening there hasn't been any news at
all about it do you think the movie
would actually happen
or is it just a rumor the creator got
fired one of the biggest and most
shocking news for the loud house fans
definitely has to be the fact that Chris
Savino the creator of the show got fired
yeah you can get fired from your own
show Chris got fired after no less than
12 women came forward and accused him of
inappropriate behavior
the reports date back to at least a
decade and many women who have dated him
have stated that Chris has threatened to
blacklist them after their relationship
ended
this was happening for over a decade
Nickelodeon took the accusations very
seriously and removed Chris Savino from
his own show since then he hasn't
returned and season three is officially
the last season Chris directed Chris
didn't deny the accusations instead he
said he was sorry and that he's ashamed
this doesn't however excuse his behavior
and Chris Savino remains fired from his
own show to this day as of July 2018
it's unclear whether Chris is working on
any other projects or taking a break to
think about his actions either way this
has definitely got to be one of the
darkest truths about the show and that's
it for our video thanks for watching see
you next time
[Music]